we met Jennifer Gardner and she's really
sweet we met the very first time as she
had my book and she had read new
miracles from heaven from cover to cover
and she'd underlined and highlighted in
dog years I was definitely inspired by
who Christie is as a man Jen was always
the first choice to play Christie in the
true story that's well a miracle it made
headlines what had happened in 2011
playing with her sister Annabelle fell
30 feet into a hollow tree while
unconscious she says she went to heaven
and met Jesus the accident seemingly
cured Anna from her rare and fatal
digestive disorder heaven was very
bright and it was very peaceful and
there was no pain and that's why I
wanted this day and I sat on Jesus's lap
and I asked him if I could stay and he
said no Annabelle I have plans for you
on earth that you cannot complete in
heaven but whenever the firefighters get
you out there will be nothing wrong with
you the words i sat on Jesus's lap look
can you tell me a little bit more and
look at what did he look like he had
brown hair and a beard and he had like a
white like what they wore back then not
really like a dress but and then a
purple sash the inspiring movies all
about family and having hope in the
midst of hardships but what seems really
happened and what didn't leave in this
hospital until I know what's wrong with
my daughter this scene when Jen yells at
the doctor that's real and so is this
family reunion in the hospital but there
was a change to this dramatic rescue I
know that like when they picked out
Kylie out of the tree she was like not
awake and she had like scratches that
were all bloody all over her face but
when Anna came out she was awake she
just pushed her hair behind her ear
another Hollywood change
Queen Latifah actually looks too nothing
like the real-life character she plays
Angela Cimino and that's okay she goes
does she know I'm white Catholic and
Irish and I said yes so she goes that's
right I'm a strong black woman that's
the fact that the real-life Angela
actually loves Queen Latifah and Queen
Latifah wound up playing this character
Hey mmm I love it now see let's just go
with that still me and Bill let's just
go in this room yeah I'm awesome I think
that's fantast chapter